ce père de famille a fait son deuil des
voitures à essence en raison du prix à
la pompe et pour sa conscience
écologique il se tourne vers
l'électrique il est impatient de
recevoir la ionique 5 de Hyundai qu'il a
déjà commandé en attendant il vient au
Salon de l'auto de Montréal pour
l'essayer pour la première fois qu'on a
fait un dépôt long passé en mars en
temps attentat on a toujours pas de date
donc on espère la recevoir cette année
il n'est pas le seul à devoir passer la
demande pour les voitures électriques
est grande et les délais de livraison ne
font pas d'exception mon véhicule est
déjà commandé ce qui est en production
présentement le V6 je l'ai commandé au
mois de janvier l'année passée donc ça
fait un temps peut même aller jusqu'à 5
ans pour certains modèles de voitures
électriques les délais d'attente pour
obtenir un véhicule électrique sont
surtout dus à la conception des
batteries qui exigent énormément de
matériaux plus difficiles à extraire qui
coûte cher à extraire et aussi la
pénurie de plus électronique et tout ça
ce qu'on veut gagne très forte demande
peu importe les obstacles l'in
automobile voit son avenir dans les
véhicules verts c'est d'ailleurs la
première fois qu'au Salon de l'auto de
Montréal les manufacturiers exposent
tous au moins un modèle de véhicules
électriques ou à hydrogène la tendance
qui se servent et réelle selon
l'organisateur électrique
tout ce qui était électrique tout ce que
tu es prêt de branchable c'est ça c'est
ça Montréal Québec c'est ça puis on le
voit aujourd'hui avec 67 modèles c'est
ça il y a un manufacturier ici qui a 24
véhicules dans son emplacement 17 c'est
à peu près des voitures électriques ça
vous dit tout non la pénurie de
véhicules commence toutefois à
décourager cet homme dans les prochaines
semaines prochain mois faudra qu'on
prenne une décision toi aussi
on ne l'a pas bah dommage ça on sera un
peu triste là parce que pour le jeu
c'est ma préférée mais on est rassemblée
voir ailleurs pour lui signifie qu'il
aura à payer plus cher pour une voiture
électrique moins en demande car il ne
veut surtout pas renoncer à son projet
vert ici
Charlotte Dumoulin Radio-Canada Montréal